INSTRUCTOR: Hello, Vissers.
For this AG, we're going to
tackle basic calculations.
Now, unlike table calculations,
basic calculations
add fields into the data source.
So we're going to cover a
little bit of an overview--
how to create them.
Then we'll talk a little bit
about row level calculations
and aggregate calculations.
And then we'll look
at some examples.
So what makes them special?
Both table calculations
or basic calculations,
they really provide
efficient processing.
They can operate directionally
within a visualization.
They can add in layers of
detail and they can filter
to the bottom of the hierarchy.
There is an order of
operations in Tableau.
And calculations can
influence other data fields
that you bring into the view.
Calculations allow you to
create unique visualizations.
You can use external services
like R and Python and Matlab,
which we use a few of these
in the advanced 5400 course.
And it also is highly flexible.
It works with
blended data sources.
So as I mentioned in
the table Calc example,
I had blended sources.
I could actually use
some of those fields
in a basic calculation.
So for the Cairn,
my expectations
are that you'll be able to
recall some general concepts
and terms for this
AG, that you will
be able to apply a provided
calculation to create
an insight.
Do not worry about
memorizing how
to create a DateDiff or
an IfThen, those I believe
can easily be found
using our AI tools.
Instead, I want to
know that you can
use that to gather an
insight in Tableau,
and then you'll need to
create an ad hoc calculation.
So we'll cover those
in the adventure guide.
Here's the types
of calculations.
Again, table calcs are a level
of detail on the worksheet.
Basic calcs create
a whole new field,
and then those LOD
expressions which are
covered in the advanced course.
To create a calculated
field, you can actually
do it in many different places.
You can select analysis
the Analysis tab
and create calculated field.
You can click on an empty
area and the data plane pane.
You can do a dropdown menu.
You can double click.
There's lots of different
ways that you can do that.
There are these
data types which I
thought would be good to
just do a quick review.
So we have number
that are decimal.
So pretty self-explanatory.
And then you have
number which are whole.
Those integers there.
When you have the
date and time, it
includes those hours,
minutes, and seconds.
And then if you
just have the date,
then it's just that
month, date, and year.
Strings are series of
characters and they
can consist of alphabetic
characters, numeric characters,
symbols, special characters,
or they may even be blank.
So there's a few examples there.
Boolean is a true or false
value where 1 is true
and 1 equals 2 is false,
and then the spatial
describes a location,
line, or shape as it
relates to a spatial area.
Think about the
latitude and longitude
coordinates that are provided.
But you can also create
your own coordinates too.
So the data set that
we're going to be using
is fairly straightforward.
I'll show it to
you as soon as we
jump into the [INAUDIBLE] file.
But I'm keeping it
simple so that you
can see the power of
basic calculations.
So just a quick preview.
We're going to concatenate
strings together.
We'll do a little bit
of conditional logic.
We'll build a bar chart.
We'll then do an
If Then end logic.
We'll talk about
aggregate calculations
and how those play out.
And we'll practice making
several calculations.
So let's close that down.
And you should be on the AG
calculation start [INAUDIBLE]
file where you can see the data.
Again, we have the
data source that you
can check out and review.
But here, this is
a good practice
where I'm just bringing
everything onto the view
and creating a table to ensure
that my data has been brought
in properly, and that I'm able
to see how many marks I have.
And if all of my
information is there.
So let's go ahead.
And we're going to create
the very first calculation.
Now again, I can
go up to analysis.
I can create calculated fields.
I can do this dropdown,
create calculated field.
I can right click over here,
create calculated fields.
So many different places.
So this one right here, we're
going to call full name.
And the quick method that I like
to use is to drag in my fields
from the data pane.
So I'm going to go
ahead and drag in first.
And then I'm going
to add the plus,
and then I'll do my two quotes
and then I'll bring in my last.
Now, Tableau has already
told me that I have an error,
so I'm missing something.
It says I'm missing an operator.
So if I go back here,
I can see that I'm
missing a plus right here.
And so that is something
just to keep in mind,
that it will alert you and
provide you with some context.
You also have this
flyout right here
that provides all of the
different functions that
are available in Tableau
with a short explanation.
I do believe our AI
tools can help get us
to some of these
equations really fast,
but it's good to know that these
are tools that are available.
So let me close that up and
let me put OK down there.
Now, I've added
that and it becomes
a field in the data pane.
Do you see how that is?
And it's a dimension.
Now if I click on this
View data icon right here,
I can see my data.
And if I scroll over, I
should be able to see--
maybe I already missed it.
I wasn't paying attention,
which happens right here.
So there it is,
full name, and it's
put in the first and the
last name already together.
So if I were to extract
this data source,
then it would include these
additional calculations
that I've created.
So let's go ahead
and build and create
a couple of other calculations.
Actually, some of
these I've already
created for you so that we don't
have to spend too much time.
If you notice here on the data
pane, if there is a little--
this small equal sign, it
indicates there's a calculation.
So you can see I've got one
right here under building floor.
The full name that we just
did, gets a free night.
That's room.
And you see I've even
created some measures
so I'll open those up.
But we'll go ahead and
look at that room one.
So if I just look at
that and then edit,
you can see what I've done is
I've split the rental property
up by 1 and then also by 2.
This is according to
the different levels
of the building.
So there's a level
1 and level 2.
So what I want to do
is I'm going to look
at that rent per building.
So if I bring in rent
and place it on columns.
And then I will bring in room.
Actually, let's bring in
building first on the rows
and then we'll bring
in room on the rows.
Let's go ahead I
think that works.
You can see right
here that we're
able to build this view to
quickly see where each of these
lies.
So we've got the first
floor, we've got two of those
and we have two of 7.
So again, adding
calculated fields
creates the ability to look
at our data little bit deeper.
So let's now look at
the next one, which
is total rent per floor.
So for this one, I calculated
field of floor was created.
So right here, I'll
just do a drop down
and you can take a look
at that calculation.
It's an if then
else if statement
where I've placed in
the if and I said left
room and that's equal to 1,
then that's the first floor.
And then else if
it's the number 2,
then it will be
the second floor.
So there is that floor.
And then to apply it to the
view, we'll just take that floor
and add it to the columns.
And we'll take that rent, which
will aggregate automatically
to sum.
And then we can see that the
second floor has less rent
at 4,300 than the first
floor, which is at 5,700.
The next item I want
to share with you
has to do with aggregation
versus row level calculations.
So let's go to the next tab.
And we're going to do a
discount percent per rental.
What I've done is the discount
came in with the data.
But then, I created a second
calculation using that.
So I have some of discount
divided by sum of rent.
Now, it's important to note that
there is this aggregation that's
before it.
And it is on both
of those fields.
Sometimes individuals
get frustrated when--
Tableau doesn't like it,
when one has an aggregation
and the other one doesn't.
But Tableau requires either both
of them do or neither of them
do.
So just something
to remember when
you're creating a calculation.
Just take a look at that.
So we're going to go ahead and
create this view by placing
building onto our row.
And then we'll do room,
which that's a calculation.
And then we'll do the full
name which we just created.
And then we'll do that
start and we'll do the end.
So I've got a table
that I'm building here.
And now what I want to do is in
the data pane under measures,
we're going to just double
click these measures
and you're going to
see them populate.
So let's go ahead and
double click on rent.
And we'll double
click on discount.
And we'll double click
on discount percentage.
So notice when I did that, on
columns, it says measure names.
And now I have all of
those measure values.
If I want to add another
measure value into this view,
I can just drag it and place
it into the measure values
right here into that shelf.
So it's a little bit of
a trick to understand
how town to look at the measure
values and measure names that
are right here in Tableau.
So now let's take a
look at some of this.
We're looking at the discount.
And we're seeing here that let's
actually bring rent in first.
So to reorder this, I can
just drag rent up to the top.
And now I've got rent.
And then I have the discount
and the discount percent.
So this is the actual amount.
Now, if I wanted to have this
to be a numerical amount,
I can go here.
And in this drop down,
I can format, change
that number to a regular
number to a currency,
and then I can deselect.
So see now I've just added
that feature to the view.
So if I were to remove
some of these like end
and start and full
name, you've now noticed
or should notice that
discount has changed.
And that's because it is
calculating that discount based
upon the dimensions
that's being shown,
meaning building and room.
Now let me go back.
Let's close out this and take
a look at another calculation.
And that is discount
percent at the row level.
So let's look at
that calculation
where I did not have
any aggregation.
So it's just discount
divided by rent.
So let's go ahead and say, OK.
And let's drag that onto to
this measures value shelf.
So now we see that
these are all 0.
And we need to modify this.
So let's go ahead
and go into here.
And let's format and change
this from numbers to percentage
showing two decimal places.
Great.
Let me actually see the
entire view for this.
Oh that's too big.
So let's just fit
the width here.
So now what we see
here is that we
have the rent, the
discounted amount,
the discount percentage
on the aggregation,
and the discount percent
on the row level.
Now, I'm showing
you this because I
think it's important for
you to recognize what
happens from an
aggregation versus a row
so that you get the
right calculation.
And if you were to look
at the underlying data--
let's go back to that view.
So let's click out of
format and click View data.
You'll notice here that if I go
to the row level discount, what
it's doing is it just summing
up all of these together.
So that's what this is doing.
Whereas over here what
it's doing is it's
taking the sum of discount.
So it's adding all the discount.
Let me find out--
where's my discount?
Probably passed it already.
So sum of discount, all of
this, which happens to be $900.
And the rent where-- is
right here, which is $10,000.
And that is what it's dividing
to get the 9,000 or excuse me,
9%.
If I were to take
everything else off,
let me just actually remove
all of these dimensions.
So we're just looking here.
So that's why if I do
all the total it's 9%.
Now, if I add in New dimensions
this is going to change.
And here we have
showing that 54% which
is that row level calculation.
So I just showed this to
you so you can pay attention
that you're sometimes--
most of the time going
to need an aggregation in
front of a calculation.
But sometimes you won't.
And then you're going to get
the row level information.
Let's jump into the
rental calendar under tab,
where we get to play with
some more of this data
to create some insights.
And what I've done here is I've
already created this start date.
So this is a calculation
because you've
got that little equal sign where
I have the date and starting.
And that's going to now be
brought into the columns.
And then we'll bring in building
and we'll bring in room.
Now, one of the
things I notice here
is I don't want to
have the year here.
So I'm actually going to go down
and just have the start date.
And I'm going to change
that to exact date.
So I can see those exact
on the axes down below.
Now, what I want to
do is I'm going to add
another calculated field.
And this one was created
by nights rented.
So this one, let's
just take a look at it.
What I did is I did
a date difference.
So again bringing in
DateDiff then doing the date
and then start date
and then end date.
So let's go ahead and bring
nights rented on to size.
And then let's bring in
that full name onto label.
So now here, we're able to look
at this kind of a Gantt chart,
if you will, to see
that Mary Slessor
she rented for 7 nights
and Amy Carmichael rented
for six nights.
And then I can see on the
calendar where those reside.
So there was an
opportunity to rent here.
And Louis Charfer
rented for 14 nights.
So we want to do a little
bit of a free night analysis.
So let's go ahead and actually,
let's just duplicate this chart
instead of remaking that.
And we will.
So we're going to
use a parameter.
Now, I've already
created the parameter.
But parameters are
fairly easy to make.
You can do that here
with a dropdown.
Create a parameter, but they
give you control and options.
I'm going to show you how
to do that in conjunction
with these calculations.
So here, I've got
the free night.
And what we want to do is we
want to show the parameter.
So now I've got that right
here in the upper right corner.
Nothing else has changed.
And we can change this.
So I could even say how about on
12/12, what does that look like?
Right now, nothing's
going to happen
because I have to add in
some more information.
So let's go ahead.
And first, we're going to
add in a reference line.
And we'll drag this
onto the table.
And for this
reference line we want
to make sure and
calculate by Free night.
So this is going to help us.
And we'll use no computation.
No label.
Will be automatic line
fill above and below.
We're not going to do that.
So if I push OK
on that, then you
can see that I need to add
in another variable here.
So we're going to actually
put in go back to the data.
And let's create a
calculated field.
Let's go ahead and
create a calculation.
And we'll call that,
gets free night.
And that's where we'll use
the free night parameter
that I created earlier.
And we'll say less than or equal
to and we'll say the start date.
And then we will do an and.
And then we'll do a free night.
Whoops, let's make sure
that's in another line.
Thanks.
There we go.
And then we will do
less than or equal to.
And we'll do the end date.
This contains errors.
So let's see what it says.
A field or logical table named
gets free night-- oh, already
exists.
Oh, I've already created that.
So right there.
Well, you found out
how to make that
but that is the gets free night.
And we're going to bring
that to the color shelf.
So now we can begin to--
let's see if we
select a few dates.
So if I select some
new dates here,
I should be able to see
how the selection changes.
Let's double check to make
sure I've got everything
correct on my view.
So it looks like my reference
line needs to be updated.
So I'm going to go ahead
and right click that.
And you can just get
that right there.
Oh, and we'll select Edit.
And it looks like
it bounced back
to start date for the value.
And we're going to, oops,
not create a new parameter.
We want to use the free
night parameter right here.
So when I click OK here, now--
oh, I can see this
being updated.
Let me actually grab this.
I'm going to drop
this over here.
So now I can give
it a bright green.
This one over here too, so
I can see it better view.
And now, if I
select a new night.
Oh, there we go.
Now things are
talking to each other
in terms of the free night.
And then I can see how my
reference line is changing.
So that would help.
Maybe a business
manager understand
when and how they might
run a promotional code
and who would benefit
from it and maybe
how much they would be able to
make if they were to offer that.
So that was the
free night analysis.
So we can just remove
that additional.
The final one is the
revenue per guest.
And that is another way to use
a calculated field to just add
more complexity to your data.
And in this case,
the calculated field
is the rent minus the discount
plus the tax per night times
the nights rented.
And notice there's no
aggregation in any of these.
So this is a row
level calculation.
So what we want to do is we
want to bring in that revenue.
We want to place
it onto columns.
Oops.
And then we're going to
bring in that full name,
and bring that onto rows.
And then if we bring in
that sum of revenue let's
just command copy.
Actually, you know
what, what we need to do
is we want to highlight which
ones are making a profit.
So I'm going to show you how
to do an ad hoc calculation.
So what you'll need
to do for an ad hoc,
if you just double click
anywhere in the column rows
or marks, you can get
a pill and you can
add in an ad hoc calculation.
So I'm going to do this
one on the marks card.
And I'm going to use sum.
And then I'm going
to use revenue.
So I'll just drop that
in I would normally do.
And what if I want to know
who is less than 1,500.
So those whose rent is less
than 1,500 and false otherwise.
Oh, something's up with that.
Let me just double check
and see what I've got.
Got my-- I need
my operator here.
And then I have--
hopefully, it closed.
Probably not.
There we go.
So I need to add
in the parentheses.
So some parentheses revenue.
And now we'll apply.
So now that's working.
Great.
But it's on detail, which
doesn't really show me anything.
So if I drag this and
drop it onto color,
I will now be able to see which
of these were less than 15.
Now, I could have
just maybe even put
a reference line
right here, but I just
want to show you how to
create an ad hoc calculation.
So again, you can just
double check, double click,
and then you can
put that in there.
I've also-- if you put a
negative in front of that,
it will reverse your axes.
So that's another
fun trick to do.
So now we know
revenue per guest.
And you have done quite a few
different table calculations
or excuse me, some
calculations that
have added a lot more fields
into that very simple data
that we looked at.
So again, looking here, I've
created a lot more fields,
both dimensions
and measures that I
can use to gather
insights about my data.
So hopefully, that
was helpful to you.
We'll continue to practice some
of these basic calculations,
and you might think about using
some of them in your project.
So happy vissing.